you started out doing a soap opera yeah
which soap opera was it guiding lights
okay and on guiding light you had a
pretty insane plotline I hope that's
true of a lot of soap operas but yours
felt like it was particularly strange
hey well I mean I knew I wasn't gonna be
there for very long or I didn't plan to
be different very long so I went to the
writers early on I said give me the
craziest storyline you can in the next
year and they obliged I was a trust fund
baby who bet his his fraternity brothers
that he could be the first to deflower
the town virgin of course then fell in
love with her and she found out about my
plot and dumped me
got a new girlfriend and then I lost my
trust fund and turned to the only thing
that anyone who loses their trust fund
can which is male prostitution yes very
relatable yeah she found out about my my
prostitution gig dumped me I went crazy
killed four people kidnapped her to a
remote cabin in the woods confessed that
I'd been molested by my female teacher
and when I was a kid which was very
topical at the time and then committed
suicide by injecting myself with a
needle full of insulin in front of her
her father and her new boyfriend and
then hung on one extra day in the
hospital to confess my sins and
apologize but my favorite part of the
whole thing was that I see no flaw and
it could happen in a year yeah be
careful the choices you make but my
favorite thing was right after I
flatlined the writers came up to me at
like right after they call cut we're
like if you ever want to come back I've
always wanted to know like Wow if you're
out there man let me know oh it's
probably a twin it's no big
you